[Musique]
depuis plusieurs années on consacre
régulièrement des émissions à l'europe
on s'intéresse chaque mois à ce que font
nos voisins européens en matière de
culture d'emploi de santé de droit on a
voulu profiter profité de la journée
franco allemande du 22 janvier prochain
pour proposer à nos auditeurs une
programmation spéciale autour de
l'amitié franco allemande
alors on a reçu pour cela le soutien du
fonds citoyen franco allemand et on a
décidé de mettre en valeur l'importance
des cultures locales au sein de l'europe
avec une meilleure connaissance de la
culture allemande dans tous ses aspects
alors des plus institutionnelle au plus
artistique alors l'essence à reporter
ses des auditeurs ce l'idée c'est de
demander à nos auditeurs de nous envoyer
des vidéos où il nous explique ce que
représente pour eux l'amitié franco
allemande alors on a reçu des
témoignages très variés de personnes de
tout âge de tout horizon certains nous
ont parlé d' échanges scolaires qui
l'ont fait d'autres de jumelage entre
leur ville est une ville en allemagne
mais certains nous ont parlé aussi de la
fête parce que l'allemagne c'est aussi
synonyme de fête de soirée d'expériences
culturelles comme par exemple
l'oktoberfest que vous connaissez
sûrement et on a sélectionné plusieurs
personnes qui vont venir participer à
nos émissions spéciales et participer à
des rencontres des séminaires organisés
par la maison de l'europe de l'heure et
la maison de l'europe des yvelines
alors le programme va être assez dense
car les relations entre la france et
l'allemagne ont des formes variées c'est
ce qu'on va essayer de vous montrer
pendant toute cette semaine alors dès le
18 janvier
vous aurez l'occasion d'écouter des
entretiens avec des députés des
eurodéputés des historiens des étudiants
et même des restaurateurs qu'on a été
interviewé un peu partout en france qui
vous apporteront un éclairage sur les
relations entre la france et l'allemagne
le 27 janvier on sera en direct du
cabaret du bout des prêts à cerner la
ville avec le soutien du fonds citoyen
franco allemand on va vous proposer une
soirée spéciale qui aurait dû se faire
en public mais qui sera malheureusement
que allah l'antenne de la radio et sur
les réseaux sociaux on proposera à nos
auditeurs et internautes un tour
d'horizon de la culture allemande et
française on verra comment elles se sont
influencés avec de la chanson de
l'effeuillage burlesque de la peinture
mais aussi on parlera cinéma et musique
avec fabrice leclerc notamment
journalistes au pao paris match si je
dis pas de bêtises et enfin le samedi 30
et 31 janvier avec nos sens à reporter
dont pourparlers il ya un instant ce
sera un week-end spécial franco allemand
avec chaque heure un entretien pour
apprendre à mieux se connaître
et puis on fera une sélection des
meilleurs punchline témoignages que vous
avez pu découvrir au cours de cette
semaine pour en faire un petit recueil
papier papier pardon pour approfondir
les liens franco-allemands